hey guys it's Thursday and we've got
some good news for you that's right new
characters are rising old games are
returning and the Australian GameSpot
team is trying to figure out where to go
for lunch do let us know where you think
we should go for lunch downstairs in
that comment box yeah I think we're a
little bit over that viewer question
maybe suggesting better questions first
up it's looking like the wonderful 101
from bein at a developer Platinum Games
may be coming to Nintendo's switch sweet
I finally have something to play wait
notes the planes over Platinum Games
tweeted out an image on Twitter which
shows characters from the 2013 Wii U
exclusive action game holding what
appeared to be switched joi cons this
taste follows another tweet from the
development this week which showed off
bayonetta in both her iterations in the
colors red and blue which some people
think may be a hint that a switch port
of the 2p Natta games is coming too you
know because the joy cones are blue and
red oh I know I know
Nintendo of America president Reggie
fils-aime a recently implied that quite
a few Wii U games are likely on their
way to switch but they still want ports
to have additional elements that make
them worth buying again so fingers
crossed
next up brand new overwatch character
doom fist is now live on the public test
realm what the hell were you on this for
following a taste
earlier this week doom fist appeared
today as a playable character he's an
offensive melee character with many
Jewish skills such as a literal hand
cannon that fires a short-range burst
from his knuckles and a rocket punch
that allows him to lunge forward and
punch enemies into walls for additional
damage yeah doom fist has a passive
ability called the best defense which
provides him with temporary shields
every time he hits an enemy with an
ability his ultimate media strike a lets
doom this jump into the air before
crashing into the ground to deal
significant damage
there's no word on when doom fists will
be available for everyone but it
shouldn't be too long
oh he's not voiced by Terry Crews I'm on
sorry I'm back so that I'm sure I'm good
sighs got really excited about me to
hear him sometimes you know nice
all right well Microsoft have announced
that for Halo games are coming to
backwards compatibility and all the DLC
is gonna be free
what halo 3 halo 3 ODST halo 4 and halo
combat Evolved Anniversary will all be
playable on Xbox one later this year
you'll be able to play both the campaign
and multiplayer 343 industries also
announced that the games will support
cross generation land connections which
means you can hook up your 360 to your X
bone for some sweet local multiplayer
when the games hit the program all their
map packs will be free to ensure the
player base isn't fragmented so dust off
your old disks if you have them or grab
some digital currency to pick them up on
the Xbox store when they hit the
backwards compatibility program later
this year that's games what news for
this Thursday and we will see you guys
tomorrow for our top 5 stories on the
entire week be sure to let us know what
you cared about today down in that
comment box and we'll see you tomorrow